Well, let's bring this close to home. So, I'm going to use uncamera. I apologize to my wife right off my ass.
My wife came to me last December, maybe early January, and said, what's the spot on my herb here?
It's other shoulder. So, I tested it out with the way I tested out with kinesiology and it shows up positive for cancer.
So, skin cancer, three possible solutions.
Best case scenario, it's basal cell cancer. You can always kill that with the topical.
I use different topical creams that I test people out for. No problem. Easiest pie.
Second possible answer is that's a squamous cell cancer.
Now, that is a rage of danger in there from not too much worse than basal cell too.
Well, this could easily be a test size. It would be something very, very serious.
And third is melanoma. So, typically, if a test positive for one ointment that I use, I know it's the more serious squalus or melanoma.
That's what I tested positive for. So, you know, we eventually told our kids. I have five kids now, seven, almost seven grandkids.
And, you know, they were like, what are you going to do? You're going to go in like, okay, let's think.
Let's reason together here. The Bible says we need to reason together. We need to first ask for wisdom, right?
And then let's reason together. What would they do? They would go in there and take out a biopsy and get a diagnosis.
Great. So, now we have a name for it. How did that help? Nothing.
So, what's the treatment going to be? Chemotherapy, radiation or surgery? Are we going to do any of those? No, when I don't? No, we're not.
I'd have to ask where I'd have to hear audible voice for me to do. People say, would you do chemo or something? I would have to hear. God knows my heart.
He'd have to say, do chemo. Fine. If you want me to witness some chemo nurse, I'll go do chemo. That's fine. But, you know my heart.
So, I would have to hear that. But, in my wife's case, this is her body. It gave her all the data. Let's walk through this.
We start using the SAV on it. I kid you not. The size of it was smaller than a dime within two weeks. It was larger than this. Larger than 11.
That's what was underneath the surface as the skin broke away and ate away. That's how big it was. If they would have done a biopsy on her, they would have done a biopsy.
Oh, the borders are not clean. They would have done a deeper biopsy. The borders are not clean. They probably would have removed her clavicle. Everything. She would have had a mess.
They would full chemo, radiation, everything. She might not be with us today. It took almost 29 days, actually, for it to all come out. Of course, we used the rife. Of course, I tested her with everything else, everything that we're doing.
The whole thing came out like a giant scam.